if you want freedom I'm going to have to
fight for it
[Music]
you gentlemen are making a big mistake
this here's mr. Thurgood Marshall man is
an attorney you will treat him with the
respect that he deserves my great
granddaddy he was a slave but now slaves
now got weapons we didn't have before
we've got the law baby you going to
these town from never seen a Negro
lawyer
hard bark you need to be careful in
double-a CP very good and you're born of
another kid Joseph spell Negro serving
attack socialite in our own bedroom the
tape will show the world apart all
events will get a fair trial and you had
it face there's only 13 million Negroes
depending on you so any of you have any
competencies let's say you have enough
confidence for us all
I only represent innocent people people
of Q's because of their race that's my
mission another touch girl I need a
partner who the jury can relate to Sam
Friedman good to meet you Sam I give me
a hand with these wood you got me here
tonight
guns books mr. Friedman mommy didn't
ever grade oh my god try it now you just
sweep through towns turn up all kinds of
ugliness my life is on the line here hey
dirty Friedman hold on it what do you
want you're one of us now Sam Oh real
fighter never play games like the heat
on the battle clan I don't never be
telling us the truth he attacked me I've
advised him to accept the deal you lied
in a sworn statement why would you do
that I doubt that because the truth gets
me cute
change the nami left cuttlefish if you
want freedom
happy damn on a mission II would have to
fight for that
the only way to get to a biggest door
with the break it down
okay
[Music]
you